Let me explain why I mentioned Ucius.
Ucussibius mentions the letter
that King Abgar the Assyrian king
we call him in Assyrian Abgar Okoma
English Abgar the black he had leprosy
of the face. Now his story connects with
the shout of turn. Let me shock you a
little bit. You guys want to go in deep.
Lord, increase our numbers for your
glory. You want to go deep, right? Okay.
While in Turkey, reports reached him
about Jesus doing miracles. So, he sent
his messenger with a letter to Jesus to
be read to Jesus.
Jesus then responds to the messenger who
writes down Jesus response. And those
letters were preserved. In a nutshell,
this what he says, and I'm going to read
it for you. Sorry about that, the
lighting. In a nutshell, Abgar says, "I
have heard that you go around doing
miracles and healing people without
medicine." He goes, "I have concluded
that you're either the son of God or God
himself who's come down from heaven."
He then invites Jesus to come and heal
him. But then he says, "I've been also
told that your countrymen persecute
you." He goes, "My country is not too
big, but it's big enough for you and me.
Come." In other words, come and reign
among us.
The letter
writing down the words of Jesus sounds
like Jesus. You know how Jesus says
blessed are you? Blessed are you. The
word blessed also means happy are you.
Blessed happy are you. He responds happy
are you Abgar for is written about me
that those who did not seek me will find
me. And then Jesus says,"I
must fulfill the will of him who sent
me. But after I ascend, I will send one
of my disciples to come bless you and
heal you."
The story goes that one of the disciples
apostles went there with the shroud of
Turin
and took the shroud placed it on Abgar
and he was miraculously healed. And the
apostle also performed miraculous
healings. And Abga got realized that's
the disciple that Jesus promised to send
me and they all converted.
Who quotes these letters? Ucibius. And
this is part of the traditions church. I
I learned that from the Assyrian church.
This is part of their tradition and
backed up by a nonassyrian historian.
You got You didn't know that? Come on,
man.
Joey, you guys didn't know this.
You didn't know. I'm I'm going to read
it to you right now. Uibius
and he's not a Syrian guys. Here, go to
Sheh Google, the greatest scholar ever
lived, put shroud of Turin, Abgar, Ab
Turkey, and you guess what? When they
examined the shroud, they found pollen
and other elements that was embedded in
the shroud that shows that it was in
Israel and in Turkey. And then it made
its way to Europe. Can you guys Google
it right now? See, I'm not lying to you.
See? Oh, yeah. Well, let me give it to
you right now from now. Remember, Ucius
is not a Syrian. He's a church
historian. So, let me get it for you. I
got to find it. I did a session on it.
Ucius
Abgar, right? Abgar letter.
All right. The legend of Abgar
writer. What is it found in Ucibius? But
let me find what book of Ucibius.
Yep. It says Tarius.
Tarius came. But let me find the book.
Ucious the teacher. Yeah, but give me
the volume, man. Uibius has several
volumes, dude. Shoot.
Okay.
Give me a second, guys. Let me bring it
up.
You ready?
I don't believe it's a legend. I believe
it's real. Even Oh, no. It's a legend.
Why? Why is it a legend? Cuz you don't
like it. And this is part of the Syrian.
Go ask them about Abgar A, meaning Abgar
the black. So let's go. Right here. He
calls him Abgarus. There you go. Right
here. You ready for me to read it?
Chapter. Yep.
Here you go. Abgarus. King Abgar.
This is part of your tradition. Assyrian
calaldanss,
this is part of your tradition. Assyrian
see that the sh of turn also made its
way to Turkey. And you'll see that
according to the upgrad story,
it was the shroud of turn that was
brought to him, placed on his face to
heal him of his leprosy.
You guys got the link?
Assyrians, Calaldanss, are you proud of
how ancient your churches and that's why
God has preserved your language and your
liturgy?
Did you guys confirm that? All right.
Now, let's read it. The divinity, see
the prince of the Adessines, that's
Adessa, that's Turkey, the divinity of
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ being
reported abroad among all men on
[clears throat] account of his
wonderworking power. He attracted
countless numbers from foreign countries
lying far away from Judea
[clears throat]
who had the hope of being cured of their
diseases and all kinds of suffering. So
he's talking about Gentiles who heard
about Christ's miraculous power and
[clears throat] then whom the disciples
went and healed. For instance, the king
Abgarus
who ruled with great glory the nations
beyond the Euphrates. That's Iraq man.
Euphrates. Is the screen large enough?
Euphrates. You can see it, right? I
don't need to large it. I gave you the
link, right? Rumble.
Being afflicted with a terrible disease
which was beyond the power of human
skill to cure. See, he had leprosy of
the face from my recollection.
When he heard the name of Jesus and of
his miracles
which were attested, pray for my throat,
perfect health. You see cat hair. See
what it does when I sit here on the
couch especially cuz the cat's full of
hair here. Excuse me. Anyway,
when he heard of the name of Jesus and
of his miracles which were attested by
all with one accord, sent a message to
him by a courier and begged him to heal
his disease.
courier, right? But he did not at that
time comply with his request. Yet he
deemed him worthy of a personal letter.
You catch that? The Lord had the courier
write down his response. So here you
have the words of our Lord, what's
called a
Aragrapha.
What does that mean? Words of our Lord
not found in the canonical New Testament
but preserved by tradition.
A graa
you guys don't know there's a technical
term for sayings of our Lord that
historians and scholars believe do come
from Christ but not found in the New
Testament. They're called a graa a graa
not written
line under we got it brother. Take it
easy man. You found me.
Ah, Gra. A G R A P H A. When's the last
time you were taught this in these
channels, dude? Because people want
spiritual UFC. Okay,
[clears throat]
let's go down. I enlarge it for you guys
because you know you guys are you're
blind like me.
But he did not at that time comply with
his request. Yet he deemed him worthy of
a personal letter in which he said that
he would send one of his disciples a sec
to cure his disease and at the same time
promise salvation to himself in all his
house. Not [clears throat] long after
his promise was fulfilled. Did you hear
it? He's an historian recording the
fulfillment.
Yes, we know even eucharistic miracles
are AB. We know that, brother.
[clears throat]
For after his resurrection from the dead
and his ascend in heaven, Thomas
Assyrians,
isn't it part of your tradition that
Thomas came and Mad meaning Tadius came
and Bulmay came to the Assyrians? Here
it is. A nonassyrian historian
narrating the history of the Assyrian
church at that time 4th century
says it was Thomas that went there.
[sighs and gasps] One of 12 apostles
under divine impulse sent Tadius and
Thomas actually went there as well.
Okay. And then Thomas went to India.
Marad Tus for you Assyrians we call him
Marad
who was [clears throat] also numbered
among the seven disciples of Christ to
Adessa as a preacher and evangelist of
teaching Christ and all that our savior
had promised received through him its
fulfillment
you [clears throat] have written
evidence of these things see as an
historian he's verifying these letters
as genuine
and where did he find these letters
Look from the archives of Adessa. They
were preserved by the Assyrian church.
You think if the Lord has a courier
write down his response, you think
you're going to lose that letter?
You think?
Okay. [clears throat]
Which was at that time a royal city. For
in the public registers there which
certain contain accounts of the ancient
times, acts of a goddess, these things
have been found preerved down to the
present time.
He doesn't think it's a myth.
You see it?
He's telling you they're preserved at
the time of writing. and he went
and consulted these writings cuz he
wanted to make sure that he was going to
write an accurate history of the events
from the incarnation till 3:24 AD.
That needs to go out. Okay, I'm going to
stand up.
May sit in the kitchen again. Just wait
for God to go. Okay, now let's continue.
But there's no better way than to hear
the epistles themselves. Now what
language Assyrians which we have taken
from the archives and we have literally
translated wow in the Assyrian language
black and white in front of you.
Do you understand what he just said?
I went saw the letters. They're written
in Syriak and I have them translated
into Greek.
That's why who gives a damn people
condemn the Assyrian church. Dude, you
don't answer to them. You answer to
Christ. No, you're a notorian.
Okay. And notorious is a heretic. Well,
even if he's a heretic, doesn't mean the
entire church is heretical and they're
going to hell,
right?
Aren't there saints that you acknowledge
that if they were around today, you'd
condemn because their views would be
deemed heretical by you,
but you can't condemn them because
they're canonized as saints already in
your church.
Right now, this cat's telling me. Okay,
now let's continue.
What language? Assyrian Calaldanss.
Syriak.
Why? because these are the Assyrians and
he has to translate literally. So
[clears throat] he gives you a literal
translation of the very letters
preserved that he accessed that he saw
and he believes are genuine. So
[clears throat] don't let modern
scholars say oh this is just a myth.
This is just a tradition you know and
you know and you know we don't really
know it's historical. Uh thought it was
historical. Why should I care for your
opinion?
Here it is. copy of an epistle written
by Abddus the ruler to Jesus and sent to
him at Jerusalem by Ananas or Ananas the
swift courier. Look what he writes.
Abgarus
ruler and his name is Abgar but in Greek
you you'd add an s to decline it if it's
nominative accusative etc. Ruler to
Jesus the excellent savior. Look, he's
never seen him. But because he's heard
reports about him, he already believes
who has appeared in the country of
Jerusalem, greeting, I have re heard the
reports of you and of your cures as
performed by you without medicines or
herbs.
For it is said that you make the blind
to see and the lame to walk, that you
cleanse lepers, and he had leprosy, by
the way, and [clears throat] cast out
impure spirits and demons. that you heal
those afflicted with lingering disease
and raise the dead. Now look, and having
heard all these things concerning you,
I've concluded that one of two things
must be true. Either you are God, and
having come down from heaven, you do
these things, or else
who does these things are the son of
God. Notice that's our topic. He's God,
the son of God. He's the son of God who
is God. without seeing him. He already
concluded because he believed the
reports are true. Notice Jesus'
reputation was spreading all over the
world. And do you want proof from the
gospels that his reputation was
spreading among the nations? Do you guys
want me to prove it to you from the
gospels itself?
Do you want now confirmation from the
inspired scriptures that our Lord's
reputation was being spread all over the
world? Well, number one, how many
Gentiles did he heal that were from
Syria, right? Ty and Sidon, right?
Phoenicia. Besides that, have you not
read John 12 where it says a group of
Greeks came looking for Jesus? It says a
group of Greeks came looking for Jesus.
It says Greeks. What were Greeks doing
looking for Jesus? Because they heard
about him.
That's in John 12. But I'll show it to
you in a minute. this cat, man. I'm
telling you, it's demonic.
Anyway, now watch.
I have therefore written to you to ask
you if you take the trouble to come to
me and to heal the disease which I have.
For I've heard that the Jews are
murmuring against you and are plotting
to injure you. But I have a very small
yet noble city which is great enough for
us both. You see that Assyrians? Be
proud. your Assyrian king. He wasn't a
king on the level of Caesar. But the
ruler of the Assyrian says, "We will
glad gladly give you our land."
You understand?
Do you understand the faith of your
Assyrian ancestor, Syrian Calaldians?
He's telling the Lord,
"My country, city is big enough for you
and me. Come, live here, reign here."
The answer of Jesus to the ruler
of God by the courier Ananas. I'm going
to have to retitle this as well if you
guys don't mind. Okay.
Here are our Lord's words. Does this
sound like what you read about Jesus in
the Gospels? Blessed are you. Don't.
Doesn't that sound like Jesus?
Blessed are you
who has believed in me without having
seen me. Isn't that what he also said to
Thomas? Thomas, you have seen me and
believe. Blessed are those who do not
see yet believe.
Isn't that what our Lord said in John
20:29?
The same exact thing. Thomas, you have
to see me alive in the flesh to believe
that I am your Lord and God. Blessed are
those who do not see and yet believe.
Be proud of your church